thanks to visitors from all over the
world Barcelona has been witnessing an
economic upswing in the past five years
there's no trace of recession anywhere
to be seen
tourism is a cornerstone of the Spanish
economy and it's definitely helped it
recover from the recession the cheapest
rooms in the Majestic Hotel cost 350
euros a night completely booked out at
the moment this suite costs 2,000 euros
a night the crisis didn't pass the
majestic by but the hotel's owners took
the opportunity to invest in renovating
their premises rather than saving the
renovation work was finished by 2013
then the guests started returning and
tourism recovered across the city much
to our satisfaction but many hotel
owners feel the city authorities have
failed to see the bigger picture the
city needs to ensure that everything is
kept clean and it needs to maintain
infrastructure in top condition
so the tourism is kept afloat like many
in the tourism industry Santiago Martin
is one of the winners of the Spanish
financial crisis eighteen-year-olds one
is one of the losers he works illegally
in a hotel for 700 euros a month he
could be sacked without notice at any
time and has no social security what I'd
like is a real job a proper position
like my parents had but they don't have
that anymore
Schwann wants to improve his prospects
and is planning to study engineering as
well as keep on working
Jorge is a history graduate he was
unemployed for three years and saw no
hope of ever finding work in Spain
he's now started training as a pilot
because he says demand for pilots is
growing in China locals don't benefit in
any way from tourism just the hotel
owners the economic upswing comes at a
cost for those at the bottom of the
ladder that's always the way it goes
it's the poor who pay the highest price
Monti owns the Via Veneto one of
Barcelona's most renowned restaurants
he started out here as a weight of 50
years ago working his way up and
eventually taking it over he's critical
of the government's economic policy I
don't think you can say that enough is
being done when you see how many people
are unemployed Salvador Dali used to be
a regular here nowadays Via Veneto
steamers are wealthy tourists and
business people
Josef monofin knows a few who managed to
recover from the crisis it takes a lot
of discipline we have to be aware of
what the crisis means del problema it's
not easy I mean no sheesh
Spain's economic growth is still shaky
basically tourism is the only sector
that's in good shape that's good news
for Barcelona but many feel the city has
been turned into a playground for
visitors few of whom think about the
toll tourism takes on locals
they have to put up with the hordes of
revelers overpriced apartments and
groceries pollution and illegal tourist
accommodation all local residents want
is for stability to return to their
lives and they want the politicians to
help this happen
despite the austerity measures that are
in place but they're losing hope the
Reds are getting richer and the poor are
getting poorer the middle class is
disappearing GDP might be back on track
but that doesn't help the workers on the
contrary the crisis has not gone away no
way across the central spectrum many
agree with him things might be going
well now but they won't necessarily stay
that way the crisis taught us that it's
a cycle
and that's a lesson that Spain has
learnt the hard way